does it worry you the prospect of  violence  well I'm confident I'm confident that  and I've been on the road for six months  now  what I've seen I'm confident that I will  be able to direct it through elections I  will be able to direct this through  elections and bring about a change  but you know the other possibility is  you know you would not want it to go the  other way I would not take power if I  was at I had a weak government like I  had before it was a coalition government  10 minority always I was not strong  enough to implement rule of law I could  not bring the powerful mafias under the  law because they were they would they  had all ways of weakening me or  blackmailing me so I would only take  power this time if I have the numbers in  in the National Assembly